every time i fly into kansas city to
give a speech there's a problem
a few years ago i flew in to speak at
the university of missouri kansas city
to give a speech titled men are not
women and some wacko in the audience
attacked me and the following day the
chancellor of the university sent out an
email to the entire school
apologizing
not to me for being attacked but to
everyone else for the fact that i had
been invited in the first place
well it's deja vu all over again
this thursday i am scheduled to fly into
kansas city to give another speech this
time at washburn university in topeka
the student group that invited me wants
me to speak on the very same topic this
confusion between men and women and what
the difference is it seems to have only
gotten worse in recent years as judge
katanji jackson proved last week during
her supreme court nomination or her
confirmation hearings rather when she
could not define the word woman
yet again
the university leadership has sent out
an email
condemning me
for a speech i have not yet given
for making the bold and controversial
claim
that boys and girls are different
i received an anonymous tip last night
that has since been confirmed
that the president of the university
jerry farley
sent out a campus-wide email
preemptively condemning me for the
speech that i have yet to give
this president jerry farley i've just
confirmed with young america's
foundation
personally signed the contract inviting
me to speak he personally signed a
physical contract on march 8th saying
michael please come visit washburn
university and give your talk and now
before i even give this speech this man
is condemning me as the worst person in
the world here's what he had to say to
the washburn university community a
washburn student organization has
invited a speaker to campus who has a
history of inciting fear and distrust
while i am strongly in support of first
amendment rights i am disappointed when
those rights are used to make others
feel unwelcome and even unsafe in our
community while we support the right to
speak freely washburn university does
not condone the hate and misinformation
spread by the speaker and his supporters
now pause right there those are some
pretty bold claims
that this man is making about me
inciting fear and distrust
making others feel
unsafe spreading hate
and misinformation
what evidence does he cite for for these
defamatory claims
nothing of course
no evidence exists it's just not true
i haven't done any of those things he is
libeling and defaming me
a speaker who he personally invited to
his campus when he signed that contract
that is a personal invitation he is
endorsing the student group's invitation
he is he is defaming me in the most
vicious language he can based on
absolutely nothing
he goes on
thursday also happens to be
international trans visibility day
washburn university supports the trans
community and students who identify as
lgbtq plus
side note apparently now we're
capitalizing the t in trans i don't know
when that happened that's the new thing
so just to let you know where the rules
are
transvisibility day by some happy
coincidence or
providence perhaps he goes on
we support and stand in solidarity with
trans people around the world and
encourage you to learn more about the
issues affecting students
faculty and staff who identify as lgbtq
plus
we will continue to engage our resources
to influence the campus community
to be an inclusive place where all feel
they are protected
affirmed
and valued
an inclusive place
where everyone is affirmed and valued
except for that hate-mongering monster
michael knowles that devil himself who
has the gall to say that boys aren't
girls
at a university
except for the students who invited that
horrible monster and the faculty and
every sensible person in the history of
the world
all of whom know that men and women are
different all of whom said so until five
minutes ago when our leaders decided we
were not allowed to state basic truths
anymore
he concludes i encourage you to
celebrate the day with messages of
compassion and support with your help
this university can be a shining light
and example to the greater community
we will learn together and from each
other and we will be better people for
the effort
jerry farley
president
i hope we will learn together i hope the
excitable leftists at washburn
university president farley foremost
among them will be able to learn from my
speech on thursday about how boys and
girls are different
probably should have learned that a
little bit earlier than college pretty
sure to learn that a little bit earlier
than becoming the president of a college
but i hope
they learn basic truths about human
nature and if that's too much for them
i hope at the very least they learn that
conservatives are not going to be
bullied and silenced and forced to
kowtow to their ridiculous ideological
fantasies did you like that clip hold on
whether you did or you didn't i don't
really care subscribe anyway ring that
bell get the notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you